in this video you're going to learn how
to do polinomial long division and I'm
going to talk about how to work through
these step by step we're going to go
through three examples together so as
you get the hang of it you can try some
of these on your own so for the first
example we've got x^2 - 3x + 5 all
divided by the quantity xus 2 so the way
you want to set this up is what you're
dividing by that's going to go in front
here and what it's dividing into or the
numerator that's going to go underneath
this division so we've got x^2 - 3x + 5
okay so now what you want to do is you
want to say to yourself and you can do
this a few different ways so find the
way that you like best you could say how
many times does this first term go into
this first term now that might sound a
little confusing what what do I mean how
many times does it go in well you could
say well what's x^2 / X x^2 ided x is
just going to be X so what I do is I
like to put the X kind of lined up with
these other X's just to keep everything
kind of organized and lined
up then what you can do is you can
distribute to both of these terms so you
can see x * X is x^2 x * -2 is -2X and
then what we do is we subtract now
subtraction is the same thing as adding
the opposite so what I oftentimes like
to do is just change these signs to the
opposite and add a lot of times students
find that a little bit easier than
subtracting especially when you have a
lot of negatives
involved notice this first terms they
can canc one another out x^2 - X2 is0
and that's what you want you always want
those first terms to cancel if they
don't you know that you've you've got
the wrong value here so now you can see
we havex + 5 now we say how many times
does X go
intox or what I personally like to do is
I say to myself Mario what * X is equal
tox well I know -1 * X is equal tox and
the reason that I want these to match is
so when I subtract that first term
cancel out right but we want to
distribute the ne1 to both of these
terms so1 * X ISX -1 * -2 is positive2
we subtract or you can change the signs
to the opposite and add notice that
first term cancels out just like it did
over here and 5 + -2 is 3 now this is a
zero degree it's a constant right and
the constant or zero degree is lower
than this x to the 1st this is a first
degree when this is lower than this
this is our remainder and we take our
remainder and we put it over our divisor
so for example if I said how many times
does six go into 19 you'd say it goes in
there three times 3 * 6 is 18 with one
left over one is smaller than six so we
would put that one that remainder over
the six you remember that from earlier
on so it's the same thing here with
polinomial long division let's look at
number two a little bit more challenging
example how would we do this one well we
have the quantity in the numerator is
being divided by this quantity in the
denominator we're trying to see how many
times is x^2 + one go into that now
notice there's some missing terms here
we don't have an X so we could put a
placeholder like 0x we also don't have
an X here so we could put a placeholder
0x and the reason I put those
placeholders in there is because it
helps everything line up a little bit
easier uh what I mean by that is when
you're doing this you'll see how
everything just kind of
you know lines up and it's just easier
to solve so let's set this up okay so
now what we do is we say how many times
does x s go into 2x cubed you could do
the work off to the side like if you
wanted to come over here and say hm 2x
Cub / x^2 let's see 2 ID 1 is two and
when I divide I subtract the exponents I
get X so this would be like
2X or you could do what I like to do
which is I say what time x^2 = 2x cubed
and that's again just going to be 2x so
I'm going to put this right above the
X's you don't have to do that a lot of
times students will just put it right
here at the beginning I just like to
keep everything lined up and then what
we're going to do is we're going to
distribute the 2x to all three of these
terms so 2x * x^2 is 2x cubed 2x * 0x is
going to give us 0 x^ 2ar 2x * 1 gives
us 2X and now see everything lines up
nicely we can subtract ract which is
like adding the opposite right so I'm
just changing those signs to the
opposite now we add straight down these
first terms cancel -2X 2 - 0x2 is -2X 2
0x - 2x is -2X and I'm just going to
bring the S down just to see what we
have left here to work
with again we say how many times does
this first term go into this first term
so again we could do the work over here
to the side we could say -2X ^2 / x^2
that's going to come out out to -2 right
because X s's cancel or you can do my
personal technique which is just to say
what * x^2 equals -2X ^2 that's going to
be -2 and we're going to distribute to
all three of these terms so -2X
^2
0x and -2 and then we can subtract or
change the signs to the opposite and add
notice those first terms cancel just
like they did here -2X - 0 X is -2X 7 +
2 is 9 notice that this is X to the 1st
whereas this is X2 so when this degree
is lower than this degree that's our
remainder we put our remainder over our
divisor so let's write our final answer
here we've got 2x minus
2 okay plus our remainder -2x + 9 over
our divisor which is x^2 + 1 and that's
our
final uh quotient there so let's do one
more example let's see if you can do
this one on your own and we'll go
through it together okay while you're
working through this problem I wanted to
ask you have you gotten my video courses
yet my algebra 1 my algebra 2C col
algebra video courses I've got links in
the description if you like the way I
explain things and you want to learn
more and go deeper into those uh two
classes check out those courses those
will really help you to understand and
we do go through a lot of Concepts and
uh practice examples together so if I
was going to do this one what I would do
is I would set it up like we've been
doing I'd take the denominator and I'd
see how many times it goes into this
numerator but notice how there's some
missing terms here we're missing an X
squ term we're also missing an X term
and so I like to put it in a descending
order here from highest to low any
missing terms put a zero again we always
take this first term and this first term
and we say how many times does X go into
X cubed that's X2 times uh and so you
can check your work because when you
multiply X2 * X is X Cub see how those
match and then X2 * -2 is -2 x^2 okay
now we're going to subtract the
subtraction is the same as adding the
opposite adding a little bit easier I
think and a lot of students do as well
especially when you have a lot of
negatives in there and then now you say
hm again these first terms X goes into
2x^2 how many times 2x or you can say
what * X is equal to 2x^2 that's going
to be 2X and we distribute so 2x^2 - 4x
now we're going to subtract or change
the signs and add notice those first
terms cancel and we're left with 4x - 8
what time x is equal to 4X that's going
to be
4 okay and 4 * X is 4X 4 * -2 is8 when
we subtract it's the same as changing
the signs to the opposite and adding and
notice on this one we have a zero
remainder so this one worked went in
evenly and we're just left with x^2 +
2x+ 4 as our quotient so great job if
you're able to follow uh this example if
you want more practice I'll put a link
to another polinomial long division
video I did right there so you can test
yourself you want to get a lot of
practice with math problems test
yourself and go ahead and check it with
that video so I'll see you over in that
video